من موسكو مجددا مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
غير ينضم الينا نور الدين لو تعطنا ايجاز
عن المعلومات حول تحطم طائره التي من
المفترض ان يمتلكها بريغوجين
نعم هو سير زمني محدد حول مسار هذه
الطائره وحول مسار بيكوجين ذاته الحديث
هنا من مسؤول سياسي للجزيره يقول بان
بيكوجين كان في افريقيا وجاء من افريقيا
الى موسكو وبعد موسكو توجه الى سان
بيترسبورغ نعلم على ان بريغوجين قبل ايام
كان قد اصدر شريطه فيديو من داخل افريقيا
واعلن وجوده في افريقيا ليعلن بعد ذلك بعد
ذلك بايام سقوط الطائره التي يقال عمليا
على الاقل ان اسمه يوجد على متن هذه
الطائره اذا الطائره انطلقت من موسكو كانت
متوجهه الى سان بيترسبورج حيث المقر
الرئيسي لشركه فاجنر لكن في الطريق في فير
في منطقه تفير تسقط هذه الطائره ليطرح او
تطرح العديد من التساؤلات هل بريغوجين على
متن الطائره كيف سقطت هذه الطائره لكن على
الاقل الان ما يتم التعاطي معه هي
الروايات الرسميه الصادره هنا في موسكو
حينما نتحدث عن الروايات الرسميه نتحدث عن
ما صدر بالتحديد عن هيئه الطيران الروسيه
التي اكدت على ان اسم يفجيني بريغوجين
موجود على مثني الطائره مجموعه من رجال
اعمال والشخصيات كانوا على متن هذه
الطائره ع اشخاص قتلوا في هذا الحادث
ثلاثه منهم هم من اطقم الطائره لكن بكل
تاكيد الان السؤال الجوهري هل فعلا ستثبت
الوقائع ستثبت المعطيات القانونيه
المعطيات الطبيه على ان بيكوجين كان فعلا
على متن الطائره خاصه في الحديث عن
التعاطي الامني لبريك وجين مع تحركاته
وتغيير مساراته وتغيير طائرته منعا لوقوع
اي حادث هل هذه المره وقع عب ريوجين في
يمكن القول في الفق واسقطت وسقط وقتل في
هذه الطائره بكل تاكيد الجميع هنا ينتظر
وكما اشرنا في وقت سابق القول الفصل في
هذه المساله هو مساله الطب الشرعي ونقل
هذه الجتات هناك حديث اعلامي هنا في روسيا
على ان الجثث تم نقلها الى احدى مستشفيات
الطب الشرعي بسانت بيترسبورغ لم يتم
تاكيدها ومن هنا من الطب الشرعي يبدا
العمل يبدا التحليل ويبدا تحديد الهويات
خاصه الهويه عبر اختبار الدي ان ايه ليتم
تاكيد هل فعلا او تاكيد الروايه الرسميه
الصادره عن هيئه الطيران او نفيها لكن
كذلك الاهم من ذلك والذي ربما الكثير من
المتابعين سواء على المستوى السياسي على
المستوى الامني هنا في داخل روسيا او حتى
خارج روسيا هي السؤال الجوهري كيف سقطت
هذه الطائره هل سقطت بفعل خلل تقني وخلل
فني ما ادى الى سقوطها ام ان هناك شخص ما
او جهه ما تقف ورا وراء اسقاط هذه الطائره
لان كل حديث هنا سيعطي تفسيرا معينا خاصه
هنا نتحدث عن شخصيه جدليه مهمه في المجال
الامني في المجال العسكري الروسي الرجل
كان له دور مهم في العمليه الاك العمليه
الروسيه وفي الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وربما برزت بشكل كبير جدا هته المجموعه في
عمليه السيطره على مدينه بخم القوه التي
سيطرت على هذه المدينه هي مجموعه فاغنر
ويمكن القول بان نقطه الخلاف الرئيسيه
والتي انفجرت في الخلاف ما بين فاغنر وما
بين وزاره الدفاع بالتحديد كانت هي منطقه
بخبت وكثير من الكلام كان يطلقه بريغوجين
في تلك الفتره في انتقاده لوزاره الداخليه
وزاره الدفاع بعدم تمويله بعدم وصول الدعم
العسكري والدعم التسليحي وكانت النقطه
التي افاضت كاس بريغوجين وفاغنر وادت الى
اعلان نوع من التمرد على السلطه العسكريه
والسيط بشكل كامل والحضور بشكل كامل على
روسف وحديث عن تحركها باتجاه موسكو اذا
هذا الرجل الامني الجدلي بهذا بهذا السياق
الذي هو سياق مناوئ ربما اذا قرئ على
المستوى السياسي للسلطه العسكريه هنا في
روسيا لكن شخصيه جدليه مهمه بمعنى الدعم
العسكري والدعم الامني للتحرك السياسي
والعسكري لروسيا وهو الحضور القوي لروسيا
وعودتها بشكل كبير الى البوابه الافريقيه
لكن من بوابه فكر الحديث عن
في افريقيا يتم الحديث بشكل مباشر عن
برجين عن فاغنر وهذا ربما يعيد نوع من
الالق السياسي لروسيا اذا الان الحديث
الان هو ماذا سيقول الطب الشرعي لتاكيد
روايه هيئه الطيران وكذلك ماذا ستقول
الاجراءات التقنيه وفحص العلبه السوداء هل
الرجل قتل هل الرجل ربما حادث عرضي وكل
حادث وكل حدث هنا وكل تفسير هنا ربما له
تفسير سياسي وتفسير امني وتفسير عسكري نور
الدين اذا ظر ان تدلي مجموعه فاجنر ببيان
وان كان يعني بريغوجين حتى الان غير معلوم
مصيره وان كان كذلك تم تحديد مصير احد
مؤسسي فاجنر وهو العقل المدبر كما يسمى
دمتري اتكين تم تاكيد وفاته في تحطم هذه
الطائره وبالتالي من الذي سيظهر للعلم وفق
متابعتك للادلاء باي بيان بخصوص
فادن
اعتقد ان فاجنر كذلك ربما قد
ينتظر المجرى والمسار السياسي والمسار
القانوني باستثناء اذا كانت لديه معطيات
اخرى ربما قد تغيب عن المشهد الاعلامي وقد
تغيب عن المشهد السياسي خاصه في مساله
بريغوجين الان الشخصيه المحوريه التي يتم
الحديث عنها هو مساله بريغوجين
ومذا وجوده بداخل الطائره فعلا اذا ما
ثبتت الروايه الرسميه لمقتل بريغوجين في
حادث الطائره وان الذي كان موجود على
الطائره والاسم الموجود على الطائره هو
اسم بريغوجين فلا اعتقد من بيان فاجنر لن
يكون الا ربما ما تذهب اليه الهيئه
الرسميه في الطب الشرعي والهيئه الرسميه
للطيران بان الرجل قد قتل وربما البيان
الذي ربما قد يصدر قد يعطي ربما المنحى
الجديد لتعاطي مجموعه فاغنر مع الواقع
الجديد في غياب بريغوجين وفي غياب اتكن
والمسار الذي تنهج عليه هل صدل فاجنر ربما
هي الذراع الخارجيه للتحرك العسكري
والسياسي والامني لروسيا داخل القاره
الافريقيه ه ربما نشهد شقاقا ما بين فاجنر
وما بين الهيئه الحاكمه هنا في روسيا على
العلم ان الكثير من الاقوال هنا تدار في
موسكو على انه رغم وجود بريغوجين ورغم
وجود اتكين وقيادتهم لمساله فاغنر لكن
الحديث دائما دائما على ان هناك من هو خلف
الستاره ويتحرك على فاغنر وربما الحديث
بشكل دقيق عن هيئه الدفاع والهيئات
العسكريه الكبرى التي ربما قد يكون لها
اليد الاكبر في اداره عمليه فاجنر وتحركات
فاجنر اذا ربما البيان ان صدر فقد ينتظر
ما ستسفر عنه الاجراءات والتحقيقات
الناجمه كما اسلفنا سابقا عن هيئه الطب
الشرعي والتي هي المكلفه بشكل كبير جدا عن
تهديد الهويه وكذلك الهيئه التقنيه
للطيران في قضيه بحث العلبه السوداء وكذلك
دراسه الوضع الميداني للطائره وتحديد هل
الطائره اسقطت بدفعات جويه ام انه بخلل في
المحرك كل هذا ربما هو الذي سيعطي النسخه
النهائيه والاخراج النهائي لبان فاجنر ولا
اعتقد ان مؤسسه كبيره امنيه عسكريه ربما
ان تنفلت خارج هذا السياق ربما الا اذا
كان فاجنر على قيد الحياه ويوجد مثلا في
لا يزال في افريقيا او لا يزال في روسيا
هنا ربما قد يكون الكلام يختلف عن اي بيان
اخر او عن اي موقف اخر طيب نور الدين يعني
انا احاول معك ان نفهم اكثر المشهد الى
اين الامور متجهه كما كنت تتحدث فاجنر هي
مؤسسه منظمه و عديدها وعتادها يعني ليس
بمسحه وبالتالي كنا تبعنا هذا الفيديو
الاخير لبريجو جين قبل حصول هذه الحادثه
انهم متواجدون في افريقيا وبالتالي مع
غياب الرجل ومع غياب شخصيات من الصف الاول
ولم يت يتم تحديد مصيرهم حتى الان كانوا
على متن الطائره ممن يتم ممن تتلقى مجموعه
فاجنر
وعناصرها اي
[تصفيق]
اوامر نعم بكل تاكيد بما ان فاغنر هي
مؤسسه عسكريه وربما التاريخ مملوء بالكثير
من هذه المجموعات القتاليه ربما هنا
نستحضر مجموعه بوب دينار الفرنسيه والتي
سبقت فاجنر بسنوات في السبعينات
والثمانينات وبدايه الستينات هته المجموعه
التي عملت الكثير ربما اكثر مما تعمله
مؤسسه فاجنر هنا من انقلابات ومن تحركات
عسكريه ومن سيطره على مجموعه من المناطق
واعلان تبعيتها لفرنسا وبالتالي المساله
هنا ربما قد لا ترتبط بشخص ما بقدر ما
ترتبط بالهيئه الاداريه والهيئه العسكريه
مؤسسه كبيره مثل مؤسسه فاجنر لا تختلف في
تفاصيلها وفي مستويات عملها عن المؤسسات
العسكريه والمؤسسات الاقتصاديه الاك
الكبرى التي لديها مجلس اداره لديها
قيادات متعدده وكما اشرت سابقا على ان حتى
الحديث هنا في موسكو قد يتحدث عن فاغنر
كانها مؤسسه مستقله عن الذراع العسكري
الروسي والمؤسسه الرسميه العسكريه الروسيه
لكن هناك من يتحدث على ان من وراء الستاره
ومن وراء الستاره الذي يحرك هذه المجموعه
قد لا يكون خارج عن المؤسسه العسكريه
الروسيه الرسميه خاصه اذا ما تتبعنا خيوط
هذه الحركه وعملها مجموعه مثل فاجنر لا
يمكن ان تتحرك بهذه الاريحيه وبهذه
السهوله على مستوى الغرب الافريقي والقيام
بهذه الانقلابات دون وجود مؤسسه عسكريه
كبيره ذات رؤيه استراتيجيه قويه للحضور
وهنا حينما نتحدث عن الحضور بكل تاكيد
روسيا كانت تامل بشكل كبير العوده الى
افريقيا نشير هنا على ان الاتحاد السوفيتي
كان حاضرا بشكل كبير في القاره الافريقيه
خلال المرحله السوفيتيه خرج من هذه
المنطقه بعد سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي الان
روسيا تعود الى افريقيا لكن من البوابه
فاجنر هل يعني ان فاجنر تتحرك لحالها بكل
تاكيد لا لان هنا يمكن ان نتحدث عن سراجيه
حضور عسكري روسي اذا الان يمكن ان نتحدث
في تفصيل اثنين التفصيل الاول هو الحديث
على ان المؤسسه هي مؤسسه كبيره مؤسسه لها
قوالبها التقنيه والاداريه والسياسيه
وبالتالي هي شخص ربما قد لا يؤثر عن
التسير الاداري لهذه اندري تشيف الذي كان
تحدث عنه بوتين بعد محاوله انقلاب
بريغوجين بفتره ودعى عناصر فاجنر بان
يلتحقوا ويتخذوا اوامر من اندريه تشيف اين
هو هذا الرجل اليوم ما المعلوم عنه هل
لازال داخل انظمه
فاجنر في الحقيقه لحد الساعه لا توجد اي
معلومات متوفره بهذا السياق كما تعلمون
على ان مساله هي مساله امنيه بامتياز واي
تحرك ربما هنا يتحرك يتحرك على ارضيه
الارضيه الاستخباراتيه ونعلم على ان
النظام الاستخباراتي الروسي ليس بالنظام
السهل ربما هو يتحرك في مجموعه من
التفاصيل و يمكن ان نشير هنا الى ان هذا
الجهاز الامني وكما اسلفت سابقا على ان من
وراء الستاره هو من يتحرك وهو من يسير
الامور اكثر ممن هم على الظاهر الظاهر
ربما قد تبدو واجهه حقيقيه واساسيه في
التعامل لكن من وراء الستاره لذلك الان ما
يحدث الان هو ماذا السؤال الجوهري الذي
يمكن الحديث عنه الان بعد غياب بريغوجين
وبعد غياب اتكن هل ماذا سيكون الوضع
القانوني والوضع العملي لمجموعه بيكوجين
هل يمكن خلق شخصيات جديده ربما قد تملا
هذا المشهد في وجه ربما خارج النطاق
الرسمي الروسي ووزاره الدفاع والمؤسسه
الامنيه والعسكريه الروسيه هل سيتم اعاده
نوع من الادماج بشكل او باخر لهذا لهذا
لهذه العلاقه ما بين ما بين فاجنر وما بين
المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه لذلك الان
الحديث عن اي تفصيل ربما قد يكون من باب
المجازفه لان المساله هنا قد تحدوها
الكثير من السريه وقد تحدوها الكثير من
المخاطر المحاذير الامنيه ربما التي تنتظر
بشكل او باخر ماذا سيتم الافراج عنه من
معلومات لذلك الان اي حديث وربما قد يكون
من باب التخمين ماذا سيحدث لفاجنر من هي
الشخصيه التي ستتولى الامور من هي الشخصيه
التي ستغادر المشهد الامني لفاجنر اذا كل
هذا يدخل من باب التخمين ما دام ان
الروايه الرئيسيه والروايه الرسميه لحد
الساعه لم تؤكد ان فاجنر قد قتل وماذا حدث
لهذه الطائره شكرا لك من موسكو مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين غير